i am therefore today making an
exceptional intervention on behalf of
the government
and providing certainty that
leaseholders in high-rise residential
buildings
will face no cost for cladding
remediation
works we will make further funding
available to pay for the removal and
replacement
of unsafe cladding for all leaseholders
in high-rise
residential buildings of 18 meters
and above or above six stories in
england
we continue to take a safety led
approach
and this funding will focus on the
higher rise buildings
where the independent expert advisory
panel tells us
time and again the overwhelming majority
of the safety
risk lies in line with the existing
building safety fund
and the anticipated scope of the new
building safety regulator
that we're establishing and will shortly
be legislating for
this will ensure that we end the
cladding scandal in a way that is fair
and generous to leaseholders
secondly for lower and medium rise
blocks of flats the risks are
significantly
lower and the remediation of cladding is
less likely to be needed in many cases
it will not be needed at all but where
it is costs can still be significant
for leaseholders which is why i'm
announcing today the government will
develop
a long-term scheme to protect
leaseholders
in this situation with financial support
for cladding remediation
on buildings between four and six
stories
under a long-term low interest scheme no
leaseholder will ever pay more than
50 pounds a month towards the removal of
unsafe cladding many far less
taken together this means the government
is providing more than
5 billion pounds including a further 3.5
billion pounds announced today plus the
significant cost
of the very generous financing scheme
which will run for many years
to come to ensure all leaseholders
in medium and high-rise blocks face
no costs or very low costs
if cladding remediation is needed
where it is costs can still be
significant
for leaseholders which
is why we want to take these important
steps we want to ensure
that the government develops this
long-term scheme which will protect
leaseholders with financial support
taken together this means that the
government
helps leaseholders to move forwards with
greater certainty
and more confidence about the future
thirdly whilst the problem is not one of
leaseholders
making it is also the case
that it cannot be right that the costs
of addressing these issues fall solely
on taxpayers
many of whom are not themselves
homeowners
and can only dream of getting on the
housing ladder
the government has always expected the
industry
to contribute towards these costs and
some
have done so today i'm announcing
that we will introduce a gateway to
developer levy
that will be implemented through the
forthcoming building safety
bill the proposed levy will be targeted
and only apply when developers seek
permission
to develop certain high-rise buildings
in england
helping to ensure the industry take
collective responsibility
for historic building safety defects
in introducing the levy we will continue
to ensure
the homes our country needs get built
and that our small and medium-sized
builders are protected